com
[Musique]
il ya un texte qui dit que le prix fort
1092 avec les fouilles archéologiques
récentes on sait que des avants l'an mil
il ya déjà des communautés religieuses
qui se relaient sur le lieu c'est un
lieu de passage en fait il ya la voie
romaine qui passait pas loin il y avait
débat qui permettait de le passer côté
chair et côté loire
donc c'est un lieu tout à fait
stratégique et en même temps qui permet
cette quiétude que les communautés
religieuses recherché
on est ici dans le jardin du prieur qui
est un jardin de la renaissance et qui
est un jardin qui est déjà évoquée à
l'époque de ronsard il imagine que
ronsard pouvait y cultiver ici les
légumes qui l'affectionné et des plantes
aussi qui l'aidait à se soigner
puisqu'il était rhumatisants donc ils
avaient besoin de recourir à certaines
plantes et en même temps voilà c'est
aussi un jardin qui témoignent des
plantes qui était un peu à la mode au
xvième siècle donc notamment les
artichauts qu'on voit encore à cette
époque les asperges et puis tout un tas
de variétés de choux qui nous viennent
aussi d'italie et qui était fortement
consommés à l'époque
en 2010 donc on refait ses vitraux en
faisant appel à un peintre justement qui
ai l'habitude de dialoguer avec des
poètes et donc ça ou qui a fait des
livres avec rené char avec yves bonnefoy
pour c'est un impôt tourangeau
quand on arrive ici on est surpris par
l'aspect monochrome en fait des vitraux
à part ceux qui sont derrière moi qu'ils
offrent un peu de couleurs mais en fait
il a travaillé comme il travaille
d'habitude dans les livres d'artistes
avec les poètes à l'encré de chine noir
donc en fait on a sous les yeux les
encres de chine qui sont du coup imprimé
sur un film polyester et qui sont
totalement transparents